Alamikum
the Mr. Chairman and all the visitors
that came here. Um thank you for having
me this opportunity and I go straight to
the question. My name is Java and I am a
student from a university in the west.
Uh I'd like uh uh to ask you about the
Bible. uh many Christians said that it's
the word of God. But the problem is that
there is so many contradictions like
440,000
stole of Solomon's horses. There's also
wife and concubine. There's also the
phrase I of those you gave me I lost
none.
>> Can you go straight to your question?
>> Yes. Uh the question is how uh many
people believe that Bible is the word of
God and how to prove that many of them
is contradictive so is not the word of
God.
>> The brother as a question that the
Christians believe that Bible is of God
and in the Bible there are many
contradictions and I do agree with you.
So if there are contradictions how can
it be the word of God? That is the
question we pose the Christian. I don't
believe Bible is the word of God. I
believe Quran is the word of God and
there are no contradictions in the
Quran. So this question should be posed
to the Christian that if you believe is
the word of God, how can the word of God
have contradictions? I have given a talk
on is the Bible God's word. I have even
had a debate Bible and Quran in the
light of science.
And when we put the test of science to
the Quran and the Bible, we find that
Quran passes the test and Bible fails
the test. So if there are scientific
errors in the Bible, if there are
mathematical contradictions, we say that
this Bible is not the original word of
God. We believe that Isaam Jesus Christ
peace be upon him, he was given the
revelation Injil.
But the present Bible is the corrupted
form of the Injil.
The present Bible has been changed.
The present Bible contains word of the
word of God also contains word of
prophet contains word of historians even
contains pornography. I'm sorry to say
it's a mixture.
So we cannot agree if I give you a clean
glass of water and add two drops of
gutter water. Will you drink it?
>> I don't think so.
>> No logical person will drink it. two
drops of gutter water. No, two drops
because it's mixed
the pure and an impure. So similarly, I
tell them if you want a pure word of
God,
this Quran is 100% the word of God.
Allah says in the Quran
in chapter 4 verse number 82,
Do they not ponder over the Quran? Had
it been from anyone besides Allah, there
have been many contradictions in it.
Hope that answers the question.